[Musique]
tapis rouge pour la première du film 23
décembre beaucoup de gros noms beaucoup
de budget une comédie sentimentale de
Noël envoie de connaître un grand succès
dans les cinémas du Québec moi j'ai
acheté du beurre de pilote pas du cacao
bio équitable du pain fait avec des
farines que j'ai jamais entendu parler
de toute ma vie je voudrais des faire
tout d'abord l'idée que notre cinéma est
hermétique n'est que pour quelques
intellectuels qui ont fait des cours en
cinéma déjà non pas du tout on raconte
des histoires qui arrivent à tout le
monde des soirs d'amour des histoires de
rencontres de deuil c'est la vie
la pandémie a fait mal à l'industrie et
les soirées comme c'est là ont été rares
depuis deux ans ce qui n'a pas empêché
l'an dernier 62 nouveaux longs-métrages
québécois documentaire ou fiction
être projeté sur nos écrans ils ont
attiré 948
000 spectateurs c'est 36% moins qu'en
2019 avant la covid les chiffres sont
encore à la baisse cette année par année
des films
par l'eau distributeur pour planifier sa
programmation à la Maison du cinéma de
Sherbrooke selon lui un film comme 23
décembre est une valeur sûre pour les
propriétaires de salles et c'est écrit
succès dessus c'est assuré ça veut dire
quoi succès en terme de rentabilité
antenne c'est un million et plus mais
les films québécois qui rapportent un
million de dollars au guichet sont rares
dans l'année on sait mais à peu près 5 à
6 films accessibles au village public
qui devrait faire 500 000 de recettes à
un million et plus c'est pas beaucoup
cinq six films
qui vont faire moins de 500 000 2550 à
500 000 puis les travailler plus en
région avoir une programmation plus
ouverte la maison du cinéma de
Sherbrooke présente au moins une
trentaine de films québécois par année y
compris des films d'auteur au sujet
moins accessibles on se cache pas c'est
pas toujours financièrement rentable
mais si on le fait pas il y aura jamais
des femmes à l'affiche mais son cinéma à
saint-salles ce qui est loin d'être le
cas de la majorité des établissements
c'est l'offre et la demande comme Jean
tantôt le nombre d'écrans nous
restreints à prendre des décisions
[Musique]
quelque chose contre moi
l'an dernier la SODEC a investi une
somme record de 49 millions et demi de
dollars dans la production de films
québécois alors que leur recette en
salle non pas dépassé 8 millions comme
un peu partout sur la planète notre
cinéma qui fait travailler 3600
personnes et largement subventionnée les
Américains ont pas besoin de subventions
parce que envahissent 80% des écrans
travers le monde nous on cherche notre
place notre identité notre discours
notre récit dans l'espace qui nous reste
et on n'est pas près de la bande de nez
de lumière parce que sinon Pascal plante
réalise des films d'auteur il procède au
montage de son troisième long métrage il
y a des films de dinde dans tous les
genres à toutes les hauteurs de budget
puis en santé à peu près dans toutes les
sphères moi je pense qu'il y a un
marasme dans le discours qui n'a pas
vraiment raison d'être
a été sélectionné au festival de canon
à perception que les gens de l'extérieur
ont du cinéma québécois elle est
vraiment positive si on s'arrête au
box-office de Mexique qu'on dirait
écouter 5 millions puis il y a fait
200000 donc c'est un échec retentissant
c'est faux j'ai fait plus d'argent en
licence de festival internationaux qui
embox office domestique ça c'est de 1
ensuite les ventes à des télés des
systèmes de type de vidéo sur demande
que c'est normal Tubize est quand même
d'avis que notre cinéma pourrait être
mieux encadré est-ce qu'on peut faire
des des sondages auprès de la population
pour voir c'est quoi qui veulent voir
aujourd'hui c'est quoi pourquoi notre
télé exemple au Québec fait encore très
bien avec les téléramans
et c'est la guerre les camps pour tous
dans les années 80 ont fait un groupe de
cinéphiles immense qui aujourd'hui à 40
ans consomme encore beaucoup beaucoup de
films tout genre de films mais on a pu
ça oui il faut aller chercher nos jeunes
là où il sent
dès le plus jeune âge les rejoindre sur
toutes les plateformes mais c'est
fondamental devant cet objectif de mieux
faire connaître ces films l'industrie a
subi un dure coût cet automne
Radio-Canada ne diffusera plus le gala
du cinéma québécois dont les codes
d'écoute étaient trop basse
l'effort mais juste une fois venir boire
un film québécois je suis garanti que
des cellules qui vont bouger dans leur
corps qui bouge pas habituellement
un appel senti après deux ans de
pandémie le Québec compte aujourd'hui
une cinquantaine d'écran du cinéma de
moins qu'en 2019
[Musique]